Over the years, a considerable number of innocent
people had unknowingly wandered into SCP-3008.
Otherwise known as the Infinite Ikea, this
extra-dimensional space more than lived up
to its nickname, consisting of an Ikea store
with no known limit to its endless aisles
upon aisles of flatpack Swedish furniture.
But given the veritable labyrinth contained
beyond the seemingly ordinary automatic doors
of SCP-3008’s entrance, it was rare that
anyone making their way inside ever made it
back out alive.
On top of that, there was little the Foundation
could do to ensure the safe return of anybody
unlucky enough to find themselves lost in
the Infinite Ikea.
Once inside, navigating a way out was made
almost impossible given the scope of the spatially
anomalous store.
And then, of course, there was the Staff.
These tall, humanoid creatures roamed the
aisles of SCP-3008, sporting a lack of facial
features, disproportionate bodies, and wearing
the typical uniform of an average Ikea worker.
“I think it’s becoming a concern,” Researcher
Conley declared.
“No, a problem, just how many people are
going missing in SCP-3008.”
“What else can we do?”
her colleague Researcher Kylan replied, shrugging
their shoulders.
“We keep watch over the entrance, stop anyone
entering.”
“But ours isn’t the only entrance,”
Conley retorted; it was true, based on evidence
gathered from some survivors that had made
it out of the Infinite Ikea, the entrance
seemed to exist in multiple parallel universes.
“Say we could figure out not just a way
navigate through SCP-3008 with better accuracy
so people can make it back out, but what if-”
“What if we could use it?”
Kylan jumped in, finishing the sentence.
“It could be like an interdimensional spaghetti
junction, a hub to access all sorts of other
alternate universes!
We could send people through the entrance
in our universe, and they could make their
way through SCP-3008 and out into another.”
“Exactly!”
their fellow researcher smiled.
“One problem, though,” they said.
“What do we do about the Staff?”
The inhabitants of the Infinite Ikea were
undoubtedly an obstacle standing in the path
of Conley and Kylan’s idea.
The faceless creatures were known to be docile
during the daytime cycle within SCP-3008,
only to turn violent and attack anyone present
when the lights dimmed.
“They’re part of the problem,” Conley
mused.
“But what if they could be part of the solution?”
The SCP Foundation hadn’t had much chance
to examine a live instance of a Staff member
– known as SCP-3008-2s – up close.
As such, they had a limited understanding
of exactly what these creatures truly were
beyond the few they had witnessed chasing
survivors out of the entrance.
Were they intelligent?
They were apparently able to speak, if only
uttering the phrase “The store is now closed,
please exit the building”.
Did they have the capacity for independent
thought, free will and emotionality?
There was only one way to find out, and so
Conley presented her plan to capture a member
of SCP-3008’s Staff for closer examination…
not knowing the bizarre chain of events that
would unfold as a result.
Drawing it out was the easy part of the plan;
after all, the Foundation knew that SCP-3008-2s
were able to react to the presence of human
beings within the Infinite Ikea.
So, Conley proposed sending in a single member
of D Class personnel, with a line of cable
attached to them, tethering them to just outside
the entrance of SCP-3008.
They were like the bait on the end of an interdimensional
fishing line, and would hopefully catch the
attention of a Staff member and lure them
out.
“What do we do once it’s out?”
Kylan had mused.
“I mean, we know so little about their biology.
We could use knockout gas, but what if they
don’t breathe?
We could tranquilize it, but what if they
don’t have blood?”
It had been the one hitch in Conley’s plan,
although she had suggested they use pure force,
trapping the Staff member like a wild animal
before bringing it back.
And sure enough, as an instance of SCP-3008-2
came racing out of the Infinite Ikea, hot
on the heels of the D Class, Foundation security
officers were able to swoop in and capture
the creature, restraining it and bundling
it into a transport back to the site.
However, upon receiving their captive Staff
member, Kylan and Conley were faced with a
new problem.
The creature seemed to be in its passive state,
it didn’t seem to be aggressive while away
from SCP-3008.
Kylan had posited their theory that the Staff’s
attack state was linked somehow to the day
and night cycles within the Infinite Ikea,
and now separated from that space, the SCP-3008-2
would remain docile.
But the larger issue was communicating with
it.
As patient as Conley tried to be with the
faceless, mouthless humanoid, it seemed to
be totally unresponsive to verbal communication.
Any question she or her colleague Kylan asked
the Staff member, it offered no response.
Dialing it back to more basic methods of communication,
it didn’t react when presented with symbols,
unphased by letters or numbers, or even straightforward
pictograms.
No matter what they tried, the Staff member
they had captured seemed not unwilling, but
unable to respond.
“There’s got to be something we haven’t
tried,” Conley urged, her frustration building
after a long day of trying to get through
to the creature.
“They’re capable of speech, we know that
from witness reports.”
“Maybe they’re a hive mind?”
Kylan mused, equally exhausted after their
efforts.
“What if it shares a consciousness with
the other Staff, like a drone in an ant colony?
Hey, that’s what we should name this one!”
they added.
“Dee for drone!”
“Can we focus here, please?”
Researcher Conley snapped.
“It’s almost like we need some way of
enhancing it, granting it the right higher
brain functions, so it has the ability to
speak with us.”
“Hold up,” her colleague replied.
“You said we need a way to enhance it…
but what if we refined it?”
What Kylan was insinuating was obvious, albeit
a direct violation of the Foundation’s own
rules.
SCP-914, otherwise known as the Clockworks,
was an anomalous contraption of unknown origin.
Two booths connected to the machine, one labeled
‘Input’ and the other ‘Output’, could
be used to disassemble, recreate, improve
or destroy an object that was placed within
SCP-914.
Although, there was yet again another hurdle
Conley and Kylan would have to attempt jumping
over: the Foundation had banned the use of
the Clockworks on biological organisms.
The pair submitted a request to their Foundation
superiors for access to SCP-914 and permission
to use it on Dee.
Kylan hadn’t expected their suggestion to
be met with anything short of a resounding
‘no’, and while determined, Conley couldn’t
help but find herself worrying about the possible,
highly likely rejection, which made it all
the more surprising that their request was
not only granted, but the experiment approved
by the O5 Council themselves.
Clearly, the highest operational staff within
the Foundation had some keen interest in whether
the Clockworks could refine an SCP-3008 Staff
member.
More likely, their interest was in what benefits
the experiment could potentially lead to.
If the Foundation possessed a refined Staff
member, its own agent within the Infinite
Ikea, the possibilities could be of great
advantage to the O5 Council.
They were less concerned with having an intermediary,
using Dee to communicate with the other SCP-3008-2s,
or negotiating the potential release of the
displaced innocent people lost in the Infinite
Ikea.
If refining Dee could mean the Council had
a way to safely reach other alternate universes
by traversing through SCP-3008, then that
bridge between worlds would be theirs to control…
Of course, Kylan and Conley were more interested
in what refining Dee could tell them about
the Staff and the nature of SCP-3008.
Did instances of SCP-3008-2 have needs, or
wants?
Could they even possess the capacity to want
things?
Were they fulfilled with their lives as anomalous
Ikea workers, and how did they navigate the
maze of endless aisles?
“Imagine it,” Conley theorized.
“If Dee can communicate with them for us,
we could open up trade with them.
The canteen inside SCP-3008 endlessly refills
with food, just picture what that could mean
if we work out a system of distributing that
resource out of the Ikea… it could change
the world!”
she exclaimed excitedly.
“Only one way to find out, right?”
Kylan replied.
They watched as Dee, their captive Staff member,
was nudged into the Input booth of SCP-914.
Conley gave the research assistants a signal
to activate the Clockworks, hoping that refining
Dee would allow them to be capable of speech
and free thought.
However, either through miscommunication – or
a secret order from above – one of the assistants
had incorrectly calibrated SCP-914.
It was meant to be set to ‘Fine’ which
would improve whatever was placed in the machine.
But instead, the dial had been turned to ‘Very
Fine’ which improved the target item to
an even greater extent – often granting
it anomalous properties.
Before anyone even noticed the change, the
gears and gyros of SCP-914 clicked and whirred
into life, making a raucous noise of moving
mechanical parts.
Destroyed in the Input booth only to be reconstituted
into something altogether new in the Output
one opposite, Dee emerged from SCP-914 after
the process was complete.
Superficially, the creature didn’t look
much different.
Its clothing seemed to have experienced the
most noticeable change.
Instead of being the usual yellow shirt and
blue trousers Ikea uniform worn by the rest
of the staff, Dee was now sporting the same
clothes, but the colors seemed to be shifting,
almost like the natural camouflage of a chameleon.
They were still faceless, their body still
incorrectly proportioned compared with a human,
and for the most part Dee seemed unchanged.
But before Kylan and Conley could move in
to take a closer look, before they were even
able to check if Dee could speak, the Staff
member vanished in the blink of an eye.
An instant state of panic erupted throughout
the Foundation facility, alarms were howling
over a containment breach, security teams
were dashing through every wing of the Site
to track down Dee.
Swept up in the chaos that quickly ensued,
Conley and Kylan received another message
from the highest point up the chain of command:
find that Staff member and bring it in alive.
Or there would be hell to pay from the O5
Council.
But somehow, there was no sign of Dee anywhere
in the facility.
They had gone, scans of the building revealed
that all members of personnel, all anomalies
and other registered forms of life were all
accounted for.
It was only when Kylan ran through the mess
hall that they realized where their refined
test subject had got to.
“Hey, turn that up!”
they yelled to a security officer who had
been quietly enjoying his lunch break.
Standing on a chair, he reached up and raised
the volume of a TV that was mounted to the
wall, overlooking the mess hall.
The screen was depicting a live news report,
the anchor on the ground standing outside
the entrance to an ordinary Ikea store.
“I’m standing outside the very store where
this bizarre turn of events has taken place,”
the anchor explained.
“Police received numerous calls regarding
sightings of an unknown figure said to be
scaring shoppers.
However, they only responded when this clip
went viral on social media.”
The report cut to cell phone footage of none
other than Dee, inside the store.
Their uniform had shifted into its typical
Ikea colors, almost like it had adapted to
suit the place it had somehow transported
itself to.
From the mess hall, Kylan watched the footage
in a mix of shock and confusion.
“Naturally, the reaction from bystanders
was one of fright at the individual’s rather
odd, faceless appearance.
Some took to Twitter, posting images calling
it some form of viral marketing hoax.
Others claimed it was a publicity stunt by
Ikea to boost sales, although, in a statement,
the company denies these accusations.
However, it was then reported that the supposed
creature began…
I’m reading this right, aren’t I?” the
anchor paused for a moment.
“Started helping customers by directing
them to store departments, recommending different
Ikea furniture and, perhaps strangest of all,
did all of this via… oh come on, really?
Telepathic communication.”
Conley had appeared in the mess hall just
in time to witness the news.
Dee had gotten free and immediately sought
out the nearest Ikea… to work there?
The next few hours contained a maddening slew
of new information bombarding the Foundation
as Researchers Kylan and Conley scrabbled
to figure out some way of recapturing Dee.
It didn’t seem that the SCP-3008-2 instance
was a danger to civilians, in fact most reports
stated that they were rather friendly.
Any customers that interacted with the creature
described its new communication patterns in
five-star reviews they apparently felt compelled
to start posting online.
“I’ve never experienced anything like
it,” one wrote.
“Dee offered the most delightful customer
service I have ever received.
That must be where they got their name, Dee
for delightful!”
“It’s not like Dee speaks in your head,”
another review explained.
“It’s more like they just give you their
thoughts, beamed directly in there.
I said ‘where can I find the Bathrooms and
Fittings department, and instantly Dee had
given me the directions, it was as if I’d
always known!”
Having an anomaly like Dee out in the open
raised all sorts of problems for the Foundation.
For one, they would have to not only scrub
every mention of the Staff member from the
internet, but also track down anyone that
interacted with Dee to administer amnestics.
But that was far from the worst of it; the
researchers had been so caught up in coordinating
a recapture effort that they didn’t realize
how rapid and extremely widespread the Dee
reviews were getting.
They were being left on customer satisfaction
boards for stores in different States, within
minutes of each other.
It took only fifteen minutes for a review
that mentioned Dee to be left in a store that
wasn’t even an Ikea outlet, but convenience
store.
“Thank you, Dee, for such lovely and speedy
service at the cashier’s desk, never had
such a nice conversation/interaction with
anyone else in the store before,” the review
read.
The news that Dee could seemingly be in multiple
places at once, appearing in different stores,
was confirmed when Conley and Kylan saw photos
posted online of the creature wearing what
looked like a number of alternate uniforms.
It seemed that Dee’s clothing – once exclusively
just an Ikea shirt and pants – switched
to match the uniform of whichever store they
starting to work in.
And the more they worked, the more places
they seemed to appear.
Perhaps the most shocking development came
almost fifty minutes after Dee had been refined
and had disappeared.
Once again turning their attention to the
news, Researcher Kylan watched as the manager
of a huge supermarket franchise store appeared
giving an interview live, talking about how
the altered SCP-3008 Staff had caused him
to change his entire business practice.
“Listen, Dee is great.
Our customers love Dee, I hear the company’s
shareholders love ‘em too.
One thing’s clear we all love Dee!” he
said jovially, but something was unnerving
about his gleeful smile.
“So, to show them our appreciation, I am
hereby announcing that – effective immediately
– all my retail staff are no longer required
to come into work.
Dee does it all, so there’s no need for
anyone else!
They’re friendlier, quieter, they work faster,
and they’re more efficient than any employee
on my payroll!
That’s right folks, Dee’s here to stay.”
Naturally, this move sparked serious controversy,
with the store’s disgruntled now-former
employees finding themselves out of work.
A number of them took to social media in an
outcry of dissatisfaction.
“This isn’t fair!
I’ve worked every weekend through college
at that store, and now I’m fired just like
that?
Thanks a lot, Dee!” one of them protested.
“It’s all a corporate ploy,” another
wrote.
“The rumor is, the only reason they’re
laying us all off so quick is because Dee
doesn’t technically count as a human employee
so they don’t have to pay them.
They’re working for free so the store manager,
and the company that owns the store, can keep
every penny of the profits.”
The justified outrage seemed to go wilfully
ignored as another store announced it would
be adopting the same policy, firing all its
staff and letting Dee take over their duties.
More and more photos started pouring in right
before Conley and Kylan’s eyes of multiple
refined SCP-3008-2 instances working behind
cashier’s desks, refilling shelves with
products, assisting customers.
Dee seemed to be acting out of instinct, like
they couldn’t help being Staff; it was their
purpose.
The horde of anomalous Staff members ended
up swarming over the country’s retail industry
simultaneously, like the drones of an ant
colony.
“Kylan, what the hell have we done?”
Conley asked, staring in disbelief at the
TV screen.
“We’ve done the unthinkable,” they answered,
equally horrified.
“We created a monster.
We took Dee out of SCP-3008 and made them
into the most powerful retail worker on the
planet.”
Within hours, every retail outlet of every
different description – not just Ikea – had
reported the firing of their entire staff,
and every business that did was now raking
in record profits.
Droves of shoppers flocked to stores, all
enjoying Dee’s customer service so much
that they were taking any excuse they could
to rush out and buy…
well, anything.
As stock supplies started to deplete, more
and more instances of the altered SCP-3008-2
appeared, taking over the supply chain and
distributing products to the various stores
they were working at, refilling the shelves
in record time.
Naturally, the O5 Council were furious.
Researchers Kylan and Conley had hoped to
present them with a refined SCP-3008 Staff
member that could allow them to better understand
the Infinite Ikea.
Now, the Council’s ulterior motive of having
access to an interdimensional bridge to other
universes had been dashed.
As if that wasn’t bad enough, and the added
hassle of Dee rapidly becoming a worldwide
sensation, the economy was destabilizing.
Thanks to the retail companies firing their
staff and hoarding massive amounts of profit
from all their stores, thanks to having Dee
compulsively working there, refining an SCP-3008
Staff member looked like it was about to collapse
the stock market and plunge the whole world
into chaos.
“Um, our bad?”
Researcher Kylan shrugged, unsure what to
say after they and Conley had just been brought
before the shadowy O5 Council to be reprimanded.
There was only one thing for it: Dee had to
be taken out of the picture, and quickly.
The more they worked, the more they seemed
to be able to multiply and spread.
Then, with a greater number of Dee instances
within a store, the faster and more efficient
they were able to work.
So, in retaliation, the O5 Council begrudgingly
activated Mobile Task Force Alpha-1, better
known by their codename, Red Right Hand.
This task force reported directly to the Council,
they were some of the Foundation’s most
loyal operatives, and it was far from their
first assassination mission.
Well, they had assumed it would be an assassination,
dispatching the Red Right Hand to the nearby
Ikea where Dee had first transported themselves
to after exiting SCP-914.
Of course, the place was overrun with Dee
duplicates.
But even after clearing out the entire store
and administering amnestics to any customers
that witnessed it, there were still plenty
more of Dee out there.
The Council quickly realized that they’d
have to send MTF Alpha-1 to every branch of
every outlet in the country, systematically
taking out every duplicate of Dee in a lengthy
clean-up operation until they were no more.
It seemed the Foundation’s personnel had
their work cut out for them; hopefully they’d
be entitled to a raise and some paid time
off after this was all over.
Now go check out “How To Actually Beat SCP-3008
The Infinite Ikea” and “I Survived 100
Days in SCP-3008...
Here's What Happened” for more of the world’s
most Hygge anomaly!